you are like okay i'm just now changing  it  i woke up one morning and it was just on  my face and i was like  okay let's just roll with it you know um  i thought i never used to have a beard  and then um  and then you know i i just i just  thought okay i think i was watching too  much like game of thrones and the  vikings oh yes  and i thought yeah you know i i think i  i just become a viking in my spare time  um but uh you know it's it also when i'm  trying to think about stuff i can do  this and it just feels good oh yeah yeah  it's like always thinking yeah it's true  yeah you just do this you look very  intelligent no you don't when you're me  but you try  okay actually you look really stupid  when you do that  but this is this is really terrible for  dude i mean he just cannot make a good  move the the position is completely lost  and also your god is just dancing almost  dancing yes  he's enjoying himself and the only the  only other